yesterday a tory mp was arrested on
suspicion of rape
today his parties say they won't suspend
him until the investigation
is complete this is a very serious
allegation
and it's right that it's treated as such
i understand that the police
are now investigating so i don't think
there's anything further that i can add
other than to say that the chief whip
and the government
are fully aware and i'm sure we'll take
all the steps that are necessary
but opposition parties are calling for
the conservatives to reconsider
with labour's shadow safeguarding
minister jess phillips saying on twitter
this is an appalling decision that sends
a message that the conservative party do
not take either their safeguarding
responsibility
or people who come forward seriously i
hope that decent tories privately
contact number 10
and their whips and express their
disgust given the seriousness of these
allegations and that suspension
uh in a workplace or anywhere else is
actually a neutral act it's a
a thing that you do in order to set off
an investigation of your own
and allow other investigations to
complete i would urge them to think
again
the alleged victim is understood to be a
young woman who used to work in
parliament the allegations span
a six-month period do you have anything
to say mr elfrick
and it comes just days after former mp
charlie elfic
was convicted of sexual assault
yet the way criminal investigations are
reported has changed since cliff richard
won a privacy case
in 2018. a police raid on the singer's
home was televised by the bbc
after a child sexual assault allegation
but mr richard was never arrested
never charged the investigation was
dropped and the police apologized
the conservatives know that if they
remove the whip from this mp and suspend
him from the party
he will become an independent mp and his
name will likely become
public and if he's never actually
charged with any criminal offence
that could unfairly damage his
reputation forever
for now the mp has been released on bail
he remains
anonymous joe pike sky news westminster